[Musique]
on va dire que le défi dont je
m'occupais qui fait partie des grands
défis du siècle c'est d'arriver à tenir
à 8 milliards sur la planète sans ce que
ça dégénère en boucherie
[Musique]
la croissance est défis climatiques sont
pas conciliables au sens où on l'entend
habituellement la croissance c'est à
dire la croissance du pib lui-même
défini de manière normatif comme la
valeur totale de la des biens et des
services qu'on produit si on prend cette
définition la du pib en fait il n'y a
pas de démonstration probante montrant
qu' on peut concilier la croissance
économique avec la lutte contre le
changement climatique
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur si
on veut limiter le réchauffement à 2
degrés vous savez ces fameux 2°
maintenant on a en tête entre l'ère
préindustrielle et 2100 il faut que
chaque année à partir de maintenant on
baisse dans le monde les émissions aussi
fort qu'en 2020 donc en 2020 on voit les
baisser de 5% dans le monde avec ce qui
s'est passé avec le co vide il faudrait
recommencer l'année prochaine à les
baisser de 5% supplémentaires et l'année
d'après de les baisser de 5%
supplémentaires encore voilà c'est ça
qu'il faut faire si on veut tenir les
deux degrés je ne connais pas de
démonstration probante disant qu'on peut
concilier cela avec la croissance
économique mais la bonne nouvelle c'est
que la croissance finira par s'arrêter
tout seul de toute façon parce que vous
n'avez pas de croissance infinie sur une
terre fini ça n'existe pas la croissance
consiste à transformer tout un tas de
trucs des minerais de fer en fourchette
des pierres de carrière en immeubles des
espaces vierges en route et c'est tout
ça consomme des ressources physiques et
vous ne pouvez rien faire croître
physiquement de façon indéfinie sur une
perfidie ça marche pas diack les
économistes pour prendre ça mais ça
marche avant
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on ne fait pas
la priorité au climat et depuis que vous
êtes nés depuis que je suis née on ne
fait aucune priorité au climat si on
regarde comment évoluent les indicateurs
physiques c'est-à-dire la quantité de
co2 dans l'atmosphère par exemple on ne
voit aucune rupture de pente depuis
qu'on a commencé à en parler il ya pas
de différence
donc c'est un peu comme si dans un
couple qui bat 16 enfants
il parlait partout du fait qu'il faut
pas les battre et continuer à les battre
comme plâtre exactement de la même
manière qu'avant c'est exactement ce que
nous faisons
donc aujourd'hui on s'en occupe pas du
climat ont dit qu'on s'en occupe mais
c'est pas vrai macroscopiquement en fait
on ne fait rien alors est-ce qu'on peut
indéfiniment ne pas s'en occuper non
parce que encore une fois sur une terre
finit le système finira par se régler à
nos dépens pour donner un rien qu'un
exemple si on a un réchauffement
climatique de l'ordre de 4 degrés ça
rendra les conditions environnantes plus
chaude que celle du sahara pour 1,5 à 3
milliards d'individus sur terre
je vous laisse imaginer la quantité de
guerre d'effondrement enfin vous voyez
bien que c'est un monde dans lequel la
croissance économique des sociétés
cotées en bourse ça sera plus vraiment
notre problème donc le enfin de la
croissance tout court pardon donc on n'a
pas le choix de ne pas s'en occuper
soit on s'en occupe ce soit le problème
s'occupe de nous
si on regarde les propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat je
suis prêt à parier alors ils semblent
révolutionnaire à une partie de la
population je suis prêt à parier que les
gens qui ont participé à la convention
eux-mêmes
il ya huit mois était pour l'essentiel
d'entre eux farouchement opposé à ce
qu'il propose aujourd'hui et je pense
que la seule question intéressante que
vos confrères devrait commencer par leur
poser n'est pas est ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre 110 ans et qu'elle est là
partent la proportion des propositions
que vous faites aujourd'hui pour
laquelle vous auriez été des opposants
il ya huit mois voilà ça c'est une
question intéressante et après la
deuxième question c'est qu'est ce qui
vous a fait changer d'avis et en fait ce
qui les a fait changer d'avis et de
comprendre l'immensité du problème
auquel on s'attaque et de comprendre
combien il est totalement à la fois
sous-évalué et mal compris dans le
pignon dans son ensemble
[Musique]